pourquoi les oiseaux volent ils sont
partout dans les villes dans les
campagnes mais comment font-ils pour
rester en l'air petit et léger grâce à
des EOS creux et des muscles puissant
sur leur torsse c'est ça le blanc du
poulet au décollage ils s'accroupissent
et déploient leurs ailes avant de sauter
en les abaissant rapidement bien plus
pratique que les avions qui doivent
prendre de l'élan l'aérodynamisme aussi
avec ses longues plumes appelées rig et
pour rester en vol ils utilisent la
physique enfin plus précisément la
portance l'air circule rapidement
audessous des ailes et exerce donc moins
de pression qu'en dessous aspirant
l'oiseau vers le haut magie pour se
diriger les oiseaux utilisent les
différents eau de leurs ailes pour
moduler la vitesse et leur queue pour
changer de direction et freiner avant
l'atterrissage voilà la prochaine fois
que vous regardez dans le ciel vous
serez